hey there I'm Phil Oh Melina and this is
a breakdown of the Walking Dead Season
six Episode eight called start to finish
and it's the mid-season finale so we've
got lots of extra stuff to cover let's
just not waste any time and get right
into it taking a look at the opening
images we start out with our little
cookie monster friend being about as
creepy as the kid can be he's listening
to every little kid's favorite kind of
music spooky old timey records and the
song he's listening to it's called
tiptoe through the tulips and you might
actually remember it as the song that
already made us hate scary little white
kids in the insidious movies so like the
Glen is Jesus opening last week I feel
like the writers really wanted to pack
this opening scene with as much as they
could so let's cover a quick few
miserable details up front and then go
into the overall parallel that they're
pushing here first as we see Sam's toy
collection we get a nice clear shot of
these unusual Legos which you might not
be surprised are actually Easter eggs
themselves these characters are
invincible Alan the alien Adam Eve and
Omni man who are all from the invincible
comics created by Robert Kirkman who
also created The Walking Dead series a
cute little shout out there then we get
a glimpse of what Sam is coloring and
instead of me describing it how about I
like Carol do it you'll be outside the
walls tied to a tree and you'll scream
and scream no one will hear you
the monsters come so yeah this is pretty
clearly the definition of being scarred
for life however short this kid's life
might be and finally we get what's
probably our most blatant metaphor we've
seen all season I know you think this is
right up my alley and it is but I don't
think we need to dive that deep into it
it's pretty obvious the ants represent
walkers the cookie is the current
version of Alexandria that pretends
everything is sugar and spice and I mean
they two literally bake cookies during a
zombie apocalypse so yeah this is pretty
accurate and it's a pretty
straightforward medical however this
overall seen this entire opener it
parallels another opening scene that I
think was a much more subtle and also a
really miscible detail in itself David
Lynch is a director who's known for
working with symbolism and imagery and
also for just kind of being a weird dude
one of his best films blue velvet is
about a small picturesque town where an
innocent youth discovers the horrors
just beneath the surface of the town and
all of the violence he encounters
totally costs and his innocence kind of
sounds like our little cookie monster
friend right so that movie has a very
famous opening sequence that clearly
establishes those themes and the
walking-dead creators definitely wanted
to reference those shots check it out we
open on a blue velvet curtain that
dissolves into a white wooden fence and
a bunch of flowers the old timey song
blue velvet kicks it our episode also
starts with the white wooden fence and
the old timey musics playing here too
then in both sequences we see a
firetruck representing the safety of a
picturesque community and blue velvet
shows us gardens and children while Sam
draws his version of a child in a garden
except it's him tied to a tree also note
this song that Sam is playing tiptoe
through the tulips it's referencing
these tulips right here in blue velvet
and while in blue velvet it opens with
some hanging blue velvet drape over in
this shot we get our version of the blue
hanging drapes in blue velvet that
feeling of safety in the community is
subverted when an old man has a stroke
and then David Lynch shows us his
metaphor for the town's darkness and
death that's just out of sight and
beneath the surface it's a bunch of
really gross insects and like a feeding
frenzy though in that moment it's
beetles and in the walking dead it's
ants but that's because a few moments
later in blue velvet our innocent
protagonist discovers an ear covered in
ants symbolizing the danger to come and
it's clearly mirrored in our scene with
the happy and cookie
pretty cool right okay since that was a
lot to point out and we still have the
entire episode to analyze I'm gonna pick
up the pace a bit and just stop when I
think there's something worth mentioning
you saw the episode right you don't need
me to tell you everything I will take
your silence as confirmation so let's
move on after the opening credits the
wall has fallen in the town is invaded
by walkers and the good news is this
keeps boyhood from maybe murdering Karl
and everyone makes a run for it some
small miserable moments here or we
realize that it was in fact Eugene who
Wyatt Lee mutters goes into the
walkie-talkie which lets us know how
this is lining up with a timeline of
Daryl Abraham and Sasha story
Rick you copy anybody go also for those
of you that think it's pretty cool that
Deanna has worked up the courage to
start shooting wildly at walkers I'm
pretty sure one of those stray bullets
is why maggie has so much trouble
running a second later notice the
miserable but very fresh bullet wound in
her freaking leg
way to go Deanna you hit something and
if you paid attention to Gabriel you
might have noticed I don't know what
happened to his prayer circle but he's
definitely wielding a head chopping
machete so there's hope for him yet and
as Rick and company take cover inside
Jesse's house we see that the
picturesque cookie of a town Alexandria
is now covered in walkers the walkers
are like the ants right remember the
metaphor alright let's keep going
skipping over Glenn and angsty Enid
we're back with Cookie Monster Sam who
is still listening to that damn song and
he's scared that the real monsters have
gotten in but he's still desperately
trying to escape the reality of that
situation which is why me closes his
door because that'll work meanwhile
Carol hangs out with her best bud Morgan
and fakes a concussion to try to get a
glimpse of who he's Heidi and there's a
nice Paul back here to the pile of
episode where just like Morgan told Rick
after they first met and Eastman - he
tells Carol Jesus is a joke we fall then
dr. Denise and the wolf man get to know
each other a little bit better and this
guy sounds a lot like angsty Enid with
his philosophy that the world is already
dead and that everyone is just living on
borrowed time
except he sees that as an excuse to do
whatever it takes to make his borrowed
time blast as long as possible including
kill anyone he needs or even wants to
kill and it sounds a lot like Enid's
just survived somehow mentality and it
makes you wonder if this guy is what
Enid would become without Glenn's
influence as dr. Denise uses her first
aid tools to dress the wolf man's wounds
we get a nice match cut over - Michonne
using her first-aid stuff on Deanna and
we learned that somewhere in the chaos
Deanna got bit
Deanna might enjoy quoting Latin but I
find this reaction much more poetic well
[ __ ] and if you're wondering when she
got bid it was probably this Walker that
she fell next to a little earlier I
guess it's just too bad that you can't
quickly chop off a torso or I don't know
maybe they should have tried that from
here on out the episode actually starts
to feel like something that they barely
ever do on this show it's an old-school
zombie movie just like in the original
Night of the Living Dead they're a group
of people hiding out inside of a
picturesque house Jesse's house actually
looks a lot like the house from out of
the Living Dead and their main goal is
just to try and block the dead from
getting in that's it it's kind of ironic
how they really do scenes like this even
though that's the whole inspiration for
this show
then Michonne gives the Anna hope that
she'll have a legacy telling her that
those plans can still work and I guess
yeah that means that Michonne is
definitely now on Team Hope I think
Deanna is just happy that even though
she's dying it doesn't mean optimism is
dead then one of the best sequences of
the episode and definitely where my
heart started to pound like crazy
Horrell finds boyhood having a full-on
meltdown and I was so sure that Carl was
gonna get shot here but he doesn't and
then a moment later he totally owns
boyhood taking his gun and telling him
your dad was an [ __ ]
and I just gotta say right here in this
moment Carl officially became a badass
like you took your time but way to go
dude you finally did it
then we get one of the best fake Walker
moments we've ever had where Deanna
almost gets brained because Rick thinks
she's a walker but she's actually just
creepily trying to grope a baby actually
I do think there's a lot more going on
here in a few moments when Deanna is
talking to Michonne and telling her that
when the time comes she'll take her own
life she named drops the episodes title
there she says it's her life start to
finish now there she means she wants to
have control of her own life even until
her dying breath but here with Judith
she actually says she just wanted to see
a baby and I think that instinct Wow a
bit weird and foolish considering her
current condition it's about the concept
of life from start to finish
she's at the end of her life and she
just wants to be consoled by seeing
someone at the beginning of their so
seeing these two together start to
finish it's just a reminder that despite
all of this hell life will go on and
these themes is starting over again keep
coming into play with Deanna
her finish as she tries to launch
everyone into their new beginning she
wants Michonne to figure out what she
wants and go after it she writes a
letter to Spencer probably wanting him
to start over again and be less of a
useless person and probably be more like
Rick she writes a letter to Maggie
trying to launch her into becoming the
town's next great political leader and
mostly she wants alexandria's people and
Rick to start over she wants him to
realize they're all the same people back
from this end a new beginning now
despite the fact that were in the middle
of such chaos on the show mark my words
I think Rick is going to come out the
other side of this actually heating her
advice like I think he's gonna see that
all of these people at least the ones
who survive they're all now part of his
group he's gonna start fresh as their
new leader taking care of everyone then
we see Eugene Terra and Rosita hiding
out in the garage that if you notice is
actually the town school which Eugene
sees as another opportunity to get his
learn on and then Rosita really worries
about Abraham and it's kind of that much
more awkward when you remember that he
just told Sasha that he wants to be with
her instead of Rosita and there's so
much drama going on right now
upstairs Carol discovers Morgan's secret
puppy and like my mean landlord she's
not cool with dogs in the house but also
they take a lot of inspiration here from
Dragon Ball Z they have really build up
this fight between the two of them with
lots and lots of debate before it though
really I think the real takeaway from me
here is that Morgan kind of sucks like
he used to be really interesting but now
I'm finding he's a crazy person like
before he was a mystery and maybe even
Noble and now that we know so much more
about him it's clear he's just trying to
mimic what Eastman taught him not long
ago he's even quoting Eastman I will not
allow you to kill me I don't want to
have to kill you I won't hurt you but
the problem with that is that Eastman
was a trained psychiatrist used to
rehabilitating deranged lunatics and
Morgan is just a guy who's maybe used to
smacking his head against the wall and
more importantly when Eastman was
housing Morgan he was only putting
himself and tabatha risks not like 50
other people and children to know Morgan
is the kind of guy that gets obsessed
with simple ideas like clearing or now
preserving life I feel like if you
handed this guy of a Scientology
pamphlet he'd changed his name to Elrond
organ or morgue ron Hubbard or something
whatever he's easily impressionable as
my points jumping ahead Morgan bodyslams
Carol and then the Wolfman gets away
with dr. Denise and I'm still just so
mad at Morgan right now
you totally caused this then Beckett
Jesse's Deanna makes a really
interesting choice she decides to
sacrifice her right to a dignified clean
death and instead like she always had
she gives her life for the greater good
deciding to use the gun to take out as
many walkers as possible instead this
also marks the full completion of her
art her desire to help people never
change but remembering that she started
out as a blind politician and here in
the last moments of her life she screams
like the warrior that she's needed to
become the one that was born through
blood and she suddenly is kind of a
badass like she even starts nailing head
shots too bad she wasn't there one the
wolf man took dr. Denise am i right and
finally we see Rick's plan to escape the
house and get to the armory and it's one
day haven't tried since season one they
cover themselves in zombie guts and
there's this really funny moment where
Sam goes downstairs and sees them his
mom's face is totally like oh damn it oh
I totally forgot about you and then
she's even like do me a favor pretend
you're not the worst it's probably not
the best parenting moment but I don't
know she's low on time she's got to
improvise as the episode nears its end
and we're onto our closing images my
heart starts to freak out again because
they're all filing out of the house
holding hands into the Walker herd and
then Sam terrifi starts to call out to
his mom
also we're not listening to your own
song earlier tiptoe through these tulips
not shout mom and now while I think this
is finally the perfect time to shove a
freaking cookie in that kid's mouth I am
going to defend his shittiness here for
a second like yeah sure it's easy to
hate on Sam but this is a kid who grew
up with an abusive dad the zombie
apocalypse then happened and then over
the course of a few days his dad kills
somebody someone else kills his dad his
town is overrun by murderers his mom has
to kill one of the murderers in his
kitchen and then the monsters that he's
so terrified of he's never had to deal
with because they've always been outside
these walls are now surrounding him so
yeah he calls for his mom because he's
scared he can't pretend to be brave he's
not Sam is the representation of
Alexandra's innocence and that's dying
right here in these very moment the
opening images for shattered all of this
Carol was right he's outside screaming
no one's listening except the monster
Sam is Alexandria Sam is the cookie and
the cookies probably about to get eaten
and now that's the episode but if you
gave in to AMC's begging and you checked
out into the Badlands you caught a bonus
scene where Daryl Abraham and Sasha meet
negan's gang and all I can say is holy
crap whatever you feel about this show
it doesn't matter anymore that negan
storyline is the best storyline in the
entire comic series and it's coming soon
I'm so freaking excited and if you don't
read the comics just know negan's kind
of like the governor times a thousand
your property now belongs to neat
get pumped look at my lingering thoughts
I think the order of the people in that
line is really important because if the
line gets messed up right at Sam I
definitely don't want to be one of the
people that's behind him and looking at
his kids it's confirmed Pete had the
worst DNA and it's not just because
they're children I know Carl is an
exception because he was born in the
darkness but even Judith who is a baby
is stuck under a poncho it's covered in
guts she's still managing to keep her
cool did baby also I saw some people on
Twitter weren't that happy with this
episode and I gotta say I kind of
understand that but trust me when I say
the stuff that's about to happen I mean
literally like in just the next few
minutes of this day it's gonna be some
of the craziest stuff Walking Dead has
ever done so hang in there Owen did we
all notice that Rick suddenly has his
signature weapon from the comics his axe
I'm pretty sure that's gonna come in
handy and my questions for you one why
do you think Gabriel made it such a big
point that he was not gonna turn back no
matter what kind of feels like maybe
he's about to abandon someone or
something maybe Sam what do you guys
think number two in the comics let's say
Judith is just nowhere near safe and the
way Carl is carrying her right now it's
really similar to a different story but
a really bad time for Judith and I know
it's dark but do you think the TV show
would ever actually be willing to hurt a
baby like I'm genuinely curious what do
you think three they want his weapon so
do you think Abraham's about the hand
over the RPG or do you think he's about
to use it let me know leave your answers
in the comments below and tweet at me
any thoughts or questions you might have
at fimo also follow at new rockstars for
updates about our videos and just nerdy
stuff we post in general and it's been
really fun doing these breakdowns for
Walking Dead I've been really busting my
ass trying to get them out so make sure
to catch up on them I think they're all
good if you miss any check them out I
also share them if you like them the
next episode season 6 episode 9 is
called no way out and it doesn't air
until Valentine's Day so find a really
creeper date to watch it with so if
they're into zombie shows they're
probably keeper I've been full of melina
keep an eye out for more Walking Dead
videos maybe I'll do some predictions
for the rest of the season maybe some
explanations of negan and the Savior's
but actually it doesn't even matter
because this show like everything else
now belongs to negan we'll see Anne
sign bye
you